fat shaming and skinny shaming are the
same actually no they're not fat people
are denied jobs proper medical care
health insurance they're paid less they
don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like phaphobia is literally
rooted in anti-blackness it's rooted in
racism and sexism how many times have
you seen marketing campaigns that are
labeled get fat quick finally add those
stubborn 30 pounds show me where all the
weight gain industries are show me all
the damaging messages that say that
skinny equals unworthy life or skinny
equals ugly but it's the last time that
you've been penalized financially when
an aircraft seed had to be accommodated
to your smaller body when is the last
time you've walked into a doctor's
office and after they weighed you stop
listening to what you were actually
there for and told you to just gain
weight because it will fix everything
fat people endure all of that and more
eat a burger is just not comparable to
systemic abuse and oppression systemic
abuse and approach that's what it all
comes down to so everybody's got to be
able to claim some kind of oppression